Schön.
Guten Tag.
Polat ist mein Name. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Erstentätig.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen eine Amnesie gespricht führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen,
möchte ich zuerst Ihre personische Daten erfahren.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Michael Schmitz.
Schmitz mit D und T.
Mit DT, richtig, ja.
Okay. Herr Schmitz, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 38 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Wann bin ich geboren?
Ich bin am 15. Juni 1984 geboren.
Okay. Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege 72 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,76 m.
Okay. Herr Schmitz, was für die Beschwerden haben Sie?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe seit ungefähr 8 Wochen immer wieder Fieber.
Ich kriege schlecht Luft.
Ich war damit vor 6 Wochen in der Uniklinik.
Die haben mir in die Nasennebenhöhlen reingeguckt.
Die haben gesagt, ich hätte eine Nasennebenhöhlenentzündung.
Ich habe 10 Tage Antibiotika-Therapie bekommen.
Die haben mich nach Hause geschickt.
Wenige Tage später hat das Ganze wieder angefangen.
Jetzt schwitzt sich mir verrückt.
Ich habe ein Gewicht verloren.
Ich kann nichts mehr essen.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich machen soll.
Ja, ein Disklone.
Ja, zuerst möchte ich über Fieber sprechen.
Seit 8 Wochen haben Sie Fieber.
Wie hoch ist ungefähr Fieber?
Das letzte Mal, als ich gemessen habe, waren es 39,5°C.
Ja, haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Ich habe öfters Paracetamol genommen.
Das geht runter, aber ein paar Stunden später kommt es wieder hoch.
Ja.
Über Ihre Luftnoten.
Tritt diese Luftnoten bei Belastung auf oder auch in Ruhe.
Ich habe keine Luftnoten.
Ich kriege nur durch die Nase keine Luft.
Ach so, okay.
Haben Sie vorher oder früher andere Infektionen überstanden,
außer Nase neben der Entzündung?
Nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Ich glaube, es ist ja immer gern gesund.
Aber Sie haben häufiger diese Entzündung?
Nein, wie gesagt, ich habe diese Beschwerden seit 8 Wochen.
Aber hier habe ich so etwas nie gehabt?
Ja, aber Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie vor 6 Wochen
eine Nase neben der Entzündung diagnostizieren.
Dann haben Sie Antwiottigung eingenommen,
aber trotzdem wieder Infektionen bekommen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das eine Infektion ist.
Wie viel haben Sie erwähnt, dass Sie Gewissverlust bekommen?
Wie viel Kilogramm?
In den letzten 8 Wochen waren es ungefähr 5 bis 6 Wochen.
Ich habe nicht mehr gewusst, wie viel Kilogramm.
Wie viel Kilogramm?
In den letzten 8 Wochen waren es ungefähr 8 Kilogramm.
Ist das unwillkürlich oder wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mein Appetit ist in den letzten 8 Wochen schlechter geworden.
Das Schwitzen.
Meinen Sie nach Schweiß oder Kalzenschweiß?
Ich schwitze sowohl Tag und Nacht.
Müssten Sie Nachtwäsche wechseln?
Nun wieder, das Bett ist dann völlig nass geschwitzt.
Ich stehe dann auf, mache die Bettwäsche neu und ziehe mich herum.
Bekommen Sie Stufrost?
Manchmal, wenn ich nass geschwitzt bin, dann ist mir auch kalz.
Herr Schmiss, haben Sie bemerkt, dass in Ihre Körperteile Blaufläcken?
Blaufläcken habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Oder ist Ihnen z.B. Nasenbluten oder Sandfleischbluten aufgefallen?
Nein, das habe ich auch nicht.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, Übelkeit habe ich nicht.
Müssten Sie sich übergeben?
Nein, das habe ich auch noch nicht.
Haben Sie Kopfschmerzen oder andere Beschwerden?
Ich habe ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen im vorderen Gesichtbereich, aber das habe ich früher nicht gehabt.
Wann haben Sie Antibiotik im Leicesters eingenommen?
Das sind, wie gesagt, ungefähr sechs Wochen her.
Ansonsten in Nähe keine Antibiotika?
Nein, in den letzten Tagen habe ich keine Antibiotika genommen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Maserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Oder kriegen Sie Luftnot?
Nein, Luftnot kriege ich auch nicht.
Ich habe nur das Gefühl, meine Nasen sind zu und ich kriege keine Luft.
Ja, das ist klar verstanden.
Haben Sie Herzklopfen oder Herzrasen wahrgenommen?
Nein, ich bin nicht aufgefallen.
Ist Ihnen in Ihrer irgendein Lämpfknoten vergrößert oder aufgefallen?
Nein, mehr habe ich jetzt nicht bemerkt.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, schwindel habe ich auch nicht.
Fühlen Sie sich müde?
Also in den letzten Wochen zunehmend.
Leistungsschwer, ich bin nicht mehr.
Also arbeiten kann ich nicht damit.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten, durchzuschlafen?
Klar, ich kriege dann keine Luft.
Ich muss dann durch den Mund atmen, dann trocknet mir alles aus.
Dann wache ich auf und kann dann nicht mehr weiter schlafen.
Okay.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit beim Hausarzt oder anderen Arzt gewesen außer Uniklinik?
Ja, nochmal bei einem HNO-Arzt.
Aber auch der hatte gesagt, das sieht aus wie eine Nasennehmendenzündung.
Ich wollte mir wieder Antibiotika verschreiben, habe ich abgelehnt.
Ansonsten waren Sie noch an der Arzt gewesen?
Nein, sonst war ich bei keinem anderen Arzt.
Jetzt bin ich hier, weil es nicht mehr geht.
Ich schaffe es nicht mehr.
Ja, alles klar, Herr Schmidt.
Leiden Sie an irgendeinem Zweifel der chronischen Erkrankungen?
Wie Bluthochdrück, Zuckerkrankheit, Schilddrösen, dysfunktionen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Sie haben keine Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, ich habe keine Vorerkrankungen.
Das will ich daraus sagen.
Ich bin 38 Jahre alt, ich will ja nicht krank sein.
Trost, da muss ich fragen, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Nee, gar keine.
Ist bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nee, nicht dass ich wüsste.
Sind Sie vorstandig geimpft?
Sie meinen jetzt gegen Covid?
Genau.
Ja, gegen Covid, wenn ich geimpft und geboost habe.
Super.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Nein, ich bin seit der Pandemie nicht mehr im Ausland gewesen.
Alles klar.
Herr Schmidt, rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche nicht, nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Grundsälten, wenn ich mal irgendwo eingeladen bin, vielleicht zum Abendessen oder so, aber sonst nicht.
Nehmen Sie sonstige Drogen?
Drogen, nein, nein, ich habe nichts mit Drogen am Hut.
Alles gut.
Was sind Sie von der Ruf Herr Schmidt?
Ich bin Ingenieur.
Welche Ingenieur sind Sie?
Ich bin Maschinenbau-Ingenieur.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Warum nicht verheiratet?
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe keine Kinder.
Wollen Sie alleine?
Ja, ich bin alleine.
Herr Schmidt, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, die sind noch am Leben.
Ja, ist in Ihrer Familie oder Ihre Eltern eine kranische Erkrankung bekannt?
Also meine Mutter hat ein bisschen mit Blutdruck zu kämpfen.
Und mein Vater hatte mal einen Herzinfarkt gehabt, aber sonst wüsste ich nicht.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwister.
Okay.
Herr Schmidt, ich würde ein paar Fragen über Ihre aktuellen Wäsche stellen.
Leiden Sie unter Selbststörungen oder O-A-Störungen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Nein, unfalle ich nicht.
Okay.
Herr Schmidt, meinerseits habe ich alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ich möchte nur, dass das aufhört, das mit dem Schwitzen
und das Luft wieder durch die Nase bekommen.
Okay.
Ich möchte Ihnen erklären, was ich machen möchte.
Jetzt werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen,
dann ein paar Diagnose-Massnahmen durchführen.
Ja.
Nach dem Ergebnis der Untersuchung und Laborergebnisse
spreche ich mit Ihnen noch einmal.
Okay?
Ja, gerne.
Danke schön.
Bitte.
Haben Kollegen noch Fragen?
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Vorne habe ich keine.
Leiden Sie unter Husten?
Nein, nicht.
Ist Ihnen dafür einen Auslöser gefallen?
Aufgefahren?
Nein.
Ich habe keine Allergien und einen Auslöser,
dafür kenne ich auch nicht.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Haben Sie Partner oder Partnerin?
Nein, seit einem Jahr keine Partnerin.
Aber vorher ja.
Vorher hatte ich eine Freundin, ja.
Keine Frage.
Haben Arsanski-Sprich anfangen?
Ja, können wir gerne bekannten.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Spülen Sie Schleim im Raffen?
Nein, Schleimproduktion habe ich nicht.
Und Husten habe ich auch nicht.
Läuft ihr eine Nase?
Oder haben Sie nur Verstoffen?
Verstoffen, da läuft nichts.
Okay.
Danke schön.
Guten Tag Herr Oberast.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patient eingenommen.
Denn ich möchte den Innenvorstellern.
Okay.
Der Patient heißt Michael Schmidt.
Er ist 38 Jahre alt und ist am 15.6. 1984 geboren.
Er ist 72 kg schwer und 1,76 m groß.
Der Patient stellte sich bei uns wegen seit acht Wochen bestehender
persisterenden Fieber und Gewichtsabnahme.
Er hat 8 kg in den acht Wochen.
Und Hyperhydrosis und Hyperhydrosis vor.
Das ist nicht ganz korrekt.
Das ist eine Hyperhydrosis.
Nachtschweiß ist nicht Hyperhydrosis.
In diesem Falle will man die Besymptomatik in den Vordergrund stellen.
Nachtschweiß.
Das ist der Fieber.
Gewichtsabnahme und Nachtschweiß.
Die Netman weiß, zusammen?
Besymptomatik.
Ja, die Besymptomatik.
Sie berichtete, dass er vor sechs Wochen wegen Sinusitis
mit Antibiotikum behandelt wurde.
Aber nach dem Antibiotikum haben wir wieder einiges Probleme gehabt.
Die Frage,
dass die Hypotomalyspne,
Selbststörungen oder Lymphopathie
verneint wurden.
Die haben auch Müdigkeit und Lastung,
mindere, die vegetativ anamnesen.
Besymptomatik.
Außerdem klagt er in Appetenz und Insomnia.
Es ist keine Vorerkrankungen bekannt.
Er nehme keine Medikamente.
Begülmäßig ein.
Es ist eine andere Medikamente.
Er nehme keine Medikamente.
Begülmäßig ein.
Er reise anamnesen ist unauffällig.
Er ist Machine-Bauer, Engineer.
Er ist Single und habe keine Kinder.
Er wohnt allein.
Er ist Unaufhällig.
Er leidet seine Mutter an Hypertonie.
Man leidet nicht an Hypertonie.
Die Anamnese ist so.
Nach bisherigen Angaben
gehe ich von einem
hematologische Malignite aus.
Sie vermuten, dass der eine Neoplasie hat.
Gehen wir Schritt für Schritt an die Sache ran.
Wenn Sie so jemanden bekommen,
Sie haben ihn untersucht.
Was machen Sie, wenn Sie den körperlichen untersuchen?
Wo nachschauen Sie, wenn Sie den untersuchen?
Ich inspeziere alle Körper,
ob es eine Hematom gibt oder
welche.
Was noch?
Man schaut auf der Hematom,
aber wo nachschaut man noch?
Bei der Inspektion meinen Sie.
Ja, bei den körperlichen Untersuchungen.
Zum Beispiel irgendwo Lymphknoten
zu tasten.
Ja, von Hals bis in die Leisten.
Was machen Sie noch?
Sie gucken, ob die Milztast bei ist.
Sie gucken zum Beispiel,
ob irgendwelche Resistenzen im Bauchraum da sind,
die Sie spüren.
Wir haben ihn aber untersucht
und Ihnen ist nichts aufgefallen.
Hat keine Lymphknoten
und die Milztast aber nicht tastbar.
Wenn jemand in die Notaufnahme kommt,
dann nehmen Sie ja auch nur Blut auf.
Ja, ich nehme Blut ab,
bei der Untersuchung besteh' ich die Pferanzielle.
Der Blut bietet auch
Leberwerte.
Leberwerte,
Sie gucken dann Nierenwerten,
Elektrolyte
und Entzündungsparameter
und dann schauen Sie mal.
Ja, und Knochen mag
das.
Ja, nur langsam, das mag ja schon sein,
aber das ist eine Knochenmachskunktion.
Sie sehen im Labor
ein völlig normales Blutbild.
Machen Sie trotzdem eine Knochenmachskunktion?
Ja, kann ich machen,
weil der Passierend hat B-Symptomatik.
Ja.
Ich spiele für eine maligmütze.
Ja, nicht ganz richtig.
Aber am Ende werden Sie wissen, warum.
Nur wenn jetzt jemand kommt
mit solchen Symptomen,
dann müssen Sie Schritt für Schritt strategisch vorgehen.
Sie haben die Information,
die HNR-Ärzte haben den Verdacht,
auf eine Sinusitis gehabt.
Und er hat immer noch Lustnot.
Wir haben Labor abgenommen und sehen,
dass der Entzündungswert nur leicht erhöht ist,
dass die Erkürzungen ein bisschen erhöht sind.
Aber Sie sehen keine Knochenmark,
fremden oder Knochenmark,
die Zellen im herüfferen Blut.
Sie haben überhaupt keinen Hinweis
für eine hematologische Erkrankung.
Was machen Sie dann?
Jetzt müssen Sie Schritt für Schritt vorgehen.
Er sagt, da kriegt keine Luft, die Nasen sind geschwollen.
Was würden Sie also machen?
Der nächste Schritt wäre ein CT oder MRT vom Kopf.
Die Nasen nehmen und einmal angucken.
Warum kriegt dieser Mensch keine Luft?
Der Radiologe sagt,
auf beiden Seiten die großen Kieferhöhlen,
die Sinus maxillaris,
sind beide ziemlich schleimhaut verdickt
und leicht segret verhalten.
Sie sagen, es ist noch merkwürdig.
Der hat Antibiotika erhalten und das ist nicht zurückgegangen.
Jetzt muss Ihnen sofort die phrenzialdiagnostische
etwas in den Kopf kommen.
Wenn es auf Antibiotikum nicht anspricht,
der hat B-Symptomatik.
Woran müssen Sie dann denken in dem Fall?
Wirklicherweise an ein Malignis, Lymphom.
Lymphom.
Wenn jemand den Verdacht auf Lymphom hat,
dann muss man etwas machen.
CT, Torax und Maptamen.
Ja, als Räderin.
Man macht einen Staging.
Man guckt sich, ob die Lymphknotenstationen
irgendetwas bieten oder nicht.
Jetzt machen Sie bei dem man einen CT
und der Radiologe sagt, es sind keine Lymphknoten.
Servikal, Thoracal oder Abdominal.
Das Einzige, was dem aufhält,
ist, die Milch ist so merkwürdig gepflegt.
Ja, in der Milch sind so
punktartige Veränderungen.
Aber ansonsten sieht er nichts aus, Elix.
Keine Splenomegalie?
Nein, keine Splenomegalie.
In fixios sein?
Wir müssen überlegen, was machen wir damit?
Ja.
Da hat schon jemand eine gute Idee.
Eine Biopsy-Mittel für eine Renospopie.
Also HNO-ärztliche Vorstellung.
Mit der Bitte,
dass aus der Nasenschleimhaut eine Probenz
genommen werden soll.
Das macht der HNO-Arzt, aber das ist nicht so.
Das macht der HNO-Arzt, aber der Pathologe sagt,
reaktiv nichts Schlimmes, nichts Malignisses.
Jetzt stehen wir wieder da, wo wir waren.
Was machen wir jetzt?
Die Idee mit der Tuverkulose ist nicht schlecht,
aber wie gesagt,
die Lunge ist frei, hat ja einen CT-Gegart
und das sind auch keine Lymphknoten,
vergrößert. Natürlich kann man jetzt sagen,
man kann ja einen Tuverkulinen-Test machen,
gucken, ob da irgendwie Kontakt
mit Tuverkulosebakterien stattgefunden hat
oder nicht.
Die machen den Test, der ist aber unauffällig.
Milz.
Was?
Ich bin Milz-Java.
Milz, was machen wir mit der Milz?
Die Probeentnahme.
Kann man in den Milz einfach so reinstichen?
Jetzt frage ich etwas, das ist natürlich gemein.
Früher hat man gesagt, aus der Milz kann man keine Probe nehmen.
Da hat man wahnsinnige Angst,
dass die Milz blutet oder einen Einriss gibt.
Aber mittlerweile macht man das,
tatsächlich.
Und wenn man die Milz nicht mehr hat,
dann ist das ein Problem.
Wer macht so etwas?
Das können der Gastroenterologen
sonografisch gesteuert machen.
Oder aber der Radiologe CT-gesteuert.
Die Gastroenterologen sagen,
in dem Fall,
dass Milz unter dem Rippenbogen versteckt ist,
dann möchten sie nicht dran gehen.
Das ist eine große Frage.
Der kriegt die Punktions, CT-gesteuerte Punktion.
Jetzt sind wir auf die Pathologie gespannt.
Was ist da rausgekommen?
Der Pathologe sagt,
er sieht vermehrt so
riesenzellartige Granuloma.
Was ist das dann?
Eine sogenannte Granulomatosa.
So epithelitelige Granuloma.
Eine Sarkoidosa.
Jetzt stimmt nicht die Frage.
Sarkoidosa lungefrei.
Schleimhäute der Nase.
Und irgendwie nur die Milz.
Geht das?
Ja, das geht.
Es gibt verschiedene Formen der Sarkoidosa.
Es ist nicht nur eine Lungenkrankheit.
Es kann auch eine sogenannte Miljardarkoidosa geben.
Wie die Miljardroverkulose.
Das heißt, auch Organe können befallen sein.
Die Sarkoidosa kann eigentlich alles Mögliche befallen.
Die Haut, die Nase-Nebenhöhlen,
die Augen, Organe von Leber oder Milz.
Oder aber auch die Lungenalarmung.
Jetzt hat er keinen Lungenbefall.
Und wahrscheinlich einen Nase-Nebenhöhnenbefall,
den wir mit der Bio-Psy nicht nachweisen konnten.
Und die Milz beweist,
dass der eine Sarkoidosa.
Passt denn die Basium-Tomatik dazu?
Könnte sein.
Aber Sarkoidosa, nur Fieber,
gewischferlose,
nicht und meistens nicht nur
größere und hatralge.
Aber diese Patiente, keine
Symptome, nur Basium-Tomatik.
Nur Basium-Tomatik, genau so ist es.
Luftnot und Basium-Tomatik.
Was ich damit sagen will,
man darf nicht einfach nur nicht danach richten,
dass es nicht mehr in den Schönern steht,
dass das unbedingt diesen Verlauf haben muss.
Mit Atralgin, Lymphknotenvergrößerung.
Das muss nicht immer dabei sein.
Man muss einfach nur seine Theorie,
dass da etwas ist, was nicht dahin gehört.
Ich wollte von Ihnen auch nicht von Anfang an wissen,
dass das eine Sarkoidosa ist.
Die Diagnose kommt am Ende durch die Diagnostik heraus.
Sie sagen, da ist etwas nicht in Ordnung.
Da ist eine Basium-Tomatik.
Wenn ich klinisch nicht weiterkomme, mache ich Bildgebung.
Wenn ich damit nicht weiterkomme, mache ich eine Biopsie-Entnahme.
Hätte ich eine Lymphknoten-Exzipation vorgenommen,
aber wenn ich keine Lymphknoten habe,
muss ich eine Organpunktion machen.
Die Organpunktion ist beweisend.
Wenn ich weiß, dass es in der Milch
eine epitheliztelige Granulomatose,
also Sarkoidosa, nachgewiesen ist,
dann sage ich, jetzt kann ich ja auch nach bestimmten Laborparameters schauen.
Wissen Sie, nach welchen Werten man im Blut
bei Sarkoidosa schaut?
Es gibt so zwei Markern.
Danach schaut man, wenn das eine Sarkoidosa ist,
man guckt einmal nach dem ACE.
Dann sieht man, dass es eine Sarkoidosa ist.
Das ist im ACE.
ACE und, was war das andere?
Jetzt ist mir das selber entfallen.
Das sind Neopterien.
ACE und Neopterien, das sind die zwei Marker,
nach denen man schauen kann.
Wenn die erhöht sind,
dann haben sie Sarkoidosa auch irgendwo laboriechemisch bestätigt.
Aber die Histologie ist nicht so,
sondern die Sarkoidosa ist nicht so,
dass sie sich nicht bestätigt.
Aber die Histologie ist führen.
Es gibt verschiedene Formen.
Die zweite Labor, nochmal bitte.
Neopterien.
ACE, also Angehöten,
Sie convertieren, entzühlen.
Und Neopterien, das sind die zwei Parameter,
die man dann anhandeln kann.
Es gibt verschiedene Formen der Sarkoidosa,
die dann auch bestimmte
Symptome machen können.
Je nachdem, was gefallen ist,
was sie gesagt haben, Herr Gündus,
mit Atralginen oder aber
Uwitis
und Lymphknotenvergrößungen,
wie nennt man das?
Das ist ein Glößkristin.
Bestimmte Formen der Sarkoidosa.
Das ist aber nicht immer der Fall.
Es gibt auch eine Sarkoidosa der Haut.
Woher muss man jetzt bei diesem Menschen nochmal schauen,
wenn man jetzt den Verdacht hat,
oder jetzt den Hinweis hat,
dass er eine Sarkoidosa hat.
Woher guckt man noch?
Was bei der Sarkoidosa meistens immer vorkommt,
und zwar auf der Haut.
Erütema nodosum.
Das sind kleinste Erhabenheiten,
die so boilenartig in der Haut
hart werden.
Dann entsteht da drumherum so ein Vorhof,
ein Routervorhof.
Und dieses Routerareal, der wandert,
und das ist so ein Erütema nodosum.
Ein rötlicher Knoten sagt man.
Das ist eigentlich typisch für Sarkoidosa.
Danach hätte man bei diesem jungen Menschen
gucken müssen.
Vor allem an den Unterschenkeln,
an den Beinen entsteht so etwas.
Wenn er das gehabt hat,
und dieser junge Mann hat das,
man hat ihn aber nicht danach gefragt.
Das ist ihm auch gar nicht so aufgefallen.
Er hat nur gesehen, an einer Stelle hat es gejuckt,
und nach 2-3 Tagen war das Jucken weg,
aber das ist ein bisschen rot gewesen.
Wie entsteht denn so eine Sarkoidosa?
Ja, autoimmun.
Wie ist das nochmal?
Autoimmun.
Die hat das Immunsystem zurück.
Wir wissen nicht genau, warum die Sarkoidosa entsteht.
Und wie behandelt man die Sarkoidosa?
Die muss es bestehlen, oder?
Muss man das immer behandeln?
Ja, je nach Stadium, oder je nach Klinik.
Je nach Klinik, nicht nach Stadium,
weil nicht jede Sarkoidosa muss behandelt werden.
Nur wenn die Sarkoidosa Probleme macht.
Dieser junge Mann mit seiner Luftnot und mit seinem Nachtschweiß,
den würde ich behandeln.
Wie würde man den als allererstes behandeln?
Was ist da die Therapie?
Corticoid, Corticoid Therapie?
Ja, Steroide gibt.
Als allererstes Steroide gibt.
Wenn das mit Steroiden nicht stabilisiert werden kann,
dann können sie auch mit Immunsofresse rein gehen.
Das weiß ich.
Das können sie nehmen, als sie wollen.
Ob sie jetzt das Azatöprin nehmen,
oder vielleicht etwas anderes.
Oder die neueren Medikamente mit irgendwelchen Antikörpern.
Das können sie auch machen, in Fliximac, oder ähnliches.
Das bleibt ihnen überlastet.
Aber es ist schon richtig, wie Sie gesagt haben,
immunsupressiv behandelt.
Und der erste Weg ist immer Steroide.
Aber wenn jemand keine Beschwerden hat,
es ist einfach nur etwas aufgefallen,
man hat diese Acroidosie nur festgestellt,
dann wartet man meistens ab.
Man sagt, watch and wait, wieso?
Weil das manchmal auch schon alleine abheilen kann.
Das kann von alleine wieder weggehen.
Das muss nicht immer behandelt werden.
Nur wenn die Leute Probleme bekommen, klinisch, symptomatisch werden,
dann muss man das machen.
Tatsächlich habe ich vor 10 Tagen so einen jungen Mann gehabt.
Der war nicht nur in der Uniklinik in Frankfurt gewesen,
wo die HNO-Ärzte den 10 Tage Antibiotisch behandelt haben.
Nach 4 Wochen ist der bei uns in der HNO aufgenommen worden.
Die Ärzte haben wieder die Serlopferdachstdiagnose gehabt.
Die haben dem Antibiose gegeben.
Der Mann hat den Antibiotisch aufgefahren,
dass sein Fieber nicht weggeht.
Er auffiebert jeden Tag bis über 39 Grad.
Der Mann hat einen Nachtschwarzen.
Dann hat er gesagt,
jetzt müssen die Hermatogenkulogen mal draufgerufen
und sagen, was da los ist.
Er hat sofort einen CT machen lassen.
Die Radiologen haben gesagt, da ist eine Schwellung.
Das ist ein Schwellen.
Die Probeentnahme aus der Nase-Nähm-Höhle hat nicht gegeben.
Wir haben hin und her überlegt, was machen wir?
Er hat keine Lumpenoten.
Er hat eine Staging bekommen.
Er hat eine Knochenmarkspunktion bekommen.
Nicht, weil wir den Verdacht auf eine Erkrankung haben,
aber die Nase konnte man nicht nachweisen.
Da war die Überlegung,
ob er vielleicht eine Leukinie hat,
aber sein Blut war völlig unauffällig.
Sein Knochenmark war völlig unauffällig.
Da hat man keine Hinweise
für irgendeine hematologische Erkrankung gesehen.
Dann haben wir im Tumor-Bord die Gastroenterologen,
die Chirurgen und die Radiologen gefragt.
Die Frage an die Chirurgen war,
ob wir das nicht mehr rausnehmen,
damit wir wissen, was da los ist.
Die Chirurgen meinte, man kann es machen.
Dann hat der Gastroenterologe gesagt, man könnte auch funktionieren,
aber die ist zu klein, da wollen wir nicht reingehen.
Dann hat der Radiologe gesagt, für ihn ist das kein Problem.
Er sticht da rein.
Dann haben wir ihn in die Milch reinstichen lassen.
Dann kam das Ergebnis mit der Sarkoidos.
Fast zwei Monate war es ein Problem.
Er hat vom Chef ein bisschen Steroide bekommen
und die Symptomatik war Schlagartitekt.
Warum hat diese Patient immer Kiva oder B-Symptomatik?
Weil das Immunsystem verrückt spielt.
Das Immunsystem hat Probleme.
Deswegen entstehen auch diese Granulome.
Das B-System macht Probleme.
Sein Immunsystem kommt durcheinander.
So etwas wie eine Autoimmunkrankheit, wie Rheuma oder ähnliches.
Das führt dazu, dass irgendwelche, was weiß ich,
Mediatorin freigesetzt werden, die zu Fieber führen.
Das Immunsystem merkt, dass da etwas nicht stimmt.
Dadurch entsteht Fieber.
Damit das Fieber weggeht, schritzt man, damit der Körper sich abkühlt.
Das ist dann eben Nachtschwarz.
Mehr ist es nicht.
Das Immunsystem ist das Problem.
Da man aber nicht genau weiß, wo das Problem des Immunsystems liegt,
kann man auch nicht gezielsterakieren.
Man macht eine immunsofresive Therapie,
weil das Immunsystem das Problem ist.
Das Immunsystem wird mit häufigen Betroffenen?
Milch ist nicht immer betroffen.
Nein, die häufigste Sarkoidose ist ja auch eine Lungen-Sarkoidose.
Nicht Haut, Leber oder Milch.
Ich wollte einfach nur ihre Sinne sterben.
Nach dem Motto, nicht jede Böse und Tomatik
muss gleich mit einem Malignom einhergehen.
Nicht mit Begriffen herumwerfen.
Seien Sie vorsichtig, weil wenn Sie denen sagen,
das ist ein Lymphom, dann sagt er, woher wischen Sie das?
Haben Sie röntgen Augen?
Können Sie in den Körper reingucken?
Was ist da los?
Keine Diagnose, einfach nur Verdacht äußern.
Sie sagen dann, das kann Sarkoidose sein,
das kann Naturbalkulose sein, das kann auch ein Malignom sein.
Wir wollen aber jetzt eine warte 400 Diagnostik machen.
Eine besondere Sache bei Sarkoidoses ist auch noch,
wenn die Niere vor allem befallen ist,
dann kann auch eine sogenannte Hyperkalzämie entstehen.
Eine Hyperkalzämie kann manchmal auch entstehen.
Das ist aber bei ihm alles nicht der Fall gewesen.
Das war auch für uns ein bisschen irritierend,
weil der keine Lymphknoten hatte,
weil die Laborbärte völlig unauffällig waren.
Das war so ein bisschen problematisch bei den jungen Mann.
Aber am Ende ist man für mich geworden.
Das ist auch nicht sehr selten.
Mit Patienten müssen Sie immer Schritt für Schritt vorangehen.
Sie untersuchen den, sie nehmen Blut ab, sie schreiben EKG.
Sie machen gegebenenfalls ein Röntgen.
Nachdem, wenn der, wie er jetzt mit Luftnot in den Nasen nehmen und machen,
sind CT, dann brauchen Sie keine Röntgen von der Lunge.
Machen lokal eine Bildkette.
Und dann stellen Sie ihn H1 Uhr erst sich vor.
Und wenn Sie dann nicht weiter voran kommen,
machen Sie ein Staging.
Sie suchen einfach etwas.
Aber nicht immer in eine Richtung denken und da festbleiben.
Das wollten Sie nicht machen.
Das ist nicht gut.
Aber nach einer anesthetischen Angabe kann man nicht sofort
so fargoidos denken.
Nein, sollen wir auch nicht.
Sie können auch nicht anhand der Anamnese
auch von einem Lymphom sprechen.
Das können Sie auch nicht wissen.
Die Vistologie ist beweisen für ein Lymphom
oder für eine Tuberkulose oder eben für eine Sargoidos.
Oder es sollte auch eine andere Erkrankung ein Heilungsmol sein können.
Also ein Flachnepidrikationen um den Nasen nehmen können.
Es ist ja auch sein können.
Aber das hat die Vistologie nicht mehr gegeben.
Das war nicht beweisen.
War das zu schwer?
War das zu problematisch?
Das wäre aber nicht problematisch.
Nicht problematisch.
Ich denke, das wird auch sehr häufig gefragt.
Ich persönlich bin in meinem Leben 3-mal über Tuberkulose gefragt worden.
Im Studium, in der Abschlussprüfung
und auch in der Verratsprüfung.